pixar's soul is first and foremost a
kid's movie yet while it does a good job
of making its complex philosophical
questions digestible for a young
audience there are a few moments in the
movie that only the grown-ups will
really understand
here are the things only adults notice
in seoul
when joe gardner is first introduced at
the beginning of seoul he's a part-time
school band director who dreams of
becoming a professional jazz pianist
joe's dream seems set to come true when
he lands an audition with the dorothea
williams quartet
a highly respected jazz group led by
professional saxophonist dorothea
williams
as joe rushes to his tryout weaving
through the bustling new york city
streets he runs by several local
businesses
but one sign stands out as obviously
nodding to a real-life brand
jimmy's shoes adults will immediately
recognize the store name as a reference
to jimmy choo
a high-end fashion house specializing in
luxury shoes and handbags founded by
couture shoe designer jimmy choo in 1996
why soul decided to include a nod to a
real-life company when most of the other
storefronts are either nondescript or
fictional is anybody's guess
but while kids won't think twice about
the brands that appear in seoul's new
york city
adults may at least get a chuckle out of
the one they recognize
after joe falls into an open manhole and
awakens in the afterlife he finds
himself on a slow-moving conveyor belt
to the great beyond
uncertain what's just happened he asked
the first group of people he encounters
what's going on and they calmly inform
him that he's passed on
as joe panics one of the women in the
group casually observes that the actual
afterlife beats her dream about the
walrus
it's hard to know for sure what this
line is supposed to mean if anything at
all
it could be just a silly slightly
surrealist one-liner but if it's a
specific reference it may be a nod to
disney's alice in wonderland which
features a pretty disturbing song called
the walrus and the carpenter
in this bizarre musical sequence a
scheming walrus and a human carpenter
team up to lure a family of childlike
oysters away from their mother and into
a restaurant
where the walrus then distracts the
carpenter so that he can eat them all
that was a very sad story hey and
there's a moral to it
oh yes a very good moral if you happen
to be an oyster
the little oysters in alice in
wonderland do bear somewhat of a
resemblance to the unfinished souls in
the youth seminar
and when you think about it the walrus
would have been the last thing those
oysters saw before they died
is soul making a morbid reference to a
killer walrus or is it just a harmless
quip about a weird dream
you decide when joe first lands on the
conveyor belt meant to transport him to
the afterlife he's all by himself
as he runs away he comes across the trio
of souls including the walrus woman who
were more than happy to move on
instead of joining them however joe
continues to flee down the conveyor belt
and suddenly finds himself in the midst
of a dense crowd of hundreds of souls
all being shunted towards the great
beyond
there's something very disturbing about
the implication of that empty conveyor
belt suddenly becoming very busy indeed
and sure people may die every second in
real life but in the world of soul that
doesn't seem to be the case
since joe and the first group he met had
their sections of the conveyor belt all
to themselves
the most obvious explanation for the
sudden crowd is that something
catastrophic happened a few minutes
after joe fell into that manhole
resulting in massive crowds of people
all arriving in the afterlife all at
once
there are a few lines in seoul that have
significant implications for a number of
age-old debates back on earth
take the exchange in which joe asked
jerry if the use seminar is where
personalities come from and she kids joe
for believing people are just born with
them
following jerry's line to its natural
conclusion she seems to be implying that
people get their personalities
and also their souls at some point after
they are born
the process as it's laid out in the
movie seems to be that souls are first
created then given their core
personalities via the various pavilions
in the u seminar
and finally find their spark through
their mentorship under other souls who
have already lived and died
at the end of this process the souls
make the trek to earth and presumably
are assigned to a body
jerry's line seems to indicate that
those bodies already exist by that point
and that the souls arrive after birth
this little detail may not seem
particularly important or noteworthy
but it's actually a highly contentious
issue in a number of world religions and
philosophies
it certainly won't be lost on much of
seoul's adult audience
when cosmic accountant terry discovers
that the count of souls entering the
afterlife is off by one he immediately
brings his concerns to jerry raising the
alarm that the count is off
jerry unconcerned brushes him off by
assuming that he must have made a
mistake
since the count hasn't been off in
centuries reassuring right
wrong while most kids might assume that
jerry's line means that the count is
always reliable the grown-ups in the
room will quickly realize that centuries
isn't actually all that long in the
grand scheme of things
depending on when soul started filing
into the great beyond we're talking
hundreds of thousands possibly up to
millions of years of terry counting
souls
if the count hasn't been off in
centuries that could mean that a rogue
soul has dropped off the celestial grid
literally thousands of times before
do the math on this one and you might be
left wondering what happened to all
those runaway souls and whether they're
still roaming about
somewhere as a soul who hasn't yet found
her spark and thus hasn't earned her
earth pass
22 has managed to remain in the youth
seminar for millennia she has mostly
managed this by tormenting her various
mentors and refusing to cooperate in the
soul giving process
in fact 22 is refined or defiant to the
use seminar down to an art form when
she's mistakenly assigned joe as a
mentor
of course she has no intention of going
along with the system this time either
and once jerry catches her and passes
her on to joe this happens
i'm going to make you wish you never
died most people wish that 22.
[Applause]
which seems about right until you
remember that jerry is in the unique
position to actually know how most souls
feel about dying
and from the perspective of the
afterlife too while he works in the u
seminar jerry's interactions with terry
make it clear that there's a decent
amount of interaction between co-workers
and the great before and the great
beyond
so jerry admitting that most people wish
they'd never died seems to imply that
the beyond may not be so
great after all if it really was so
great why would most people wish they
were still alive
what's really going on in the great
beyond
when 22 is first introduced it quickly
becomes clear that she has absolutely no
intention of ever leaving the u seminar
for immortal life on earth indeed the
juries have spent centuries upon
centuries trying to find her the perfect
mentor that will help her find her spark
but to no avail
22 ultimately outlasts them all and in
her interactions with joe she name drops
several recognizable figures who have
tried to inspire her
including mother teresa marie antoinette
and muhammad ali
but when 22 takes joe through her home
on her way to visit the zone you can see
that she's collected all the name tags
of her past mentors
including a few familiar names some of
22's collected name tags include joan of
arc
nelson mandela harvey milk george orwell
aretha franklin amelia earhart
marvin gaye martin luther king jr johnny
cash pablo picasso
babe ruth harriet tubman and more this
is a brief scene and kids aren't likely
to recognize many of the names but it's
still a fun easter egg for the grown-ups
once 22 has agreed to help joe return to
earth the two of them embark on a tour
of the u seminar searching for 22 spark
since finding a spark is easier said
than done 22 takes him to the zone
the place that exists between the
physical and spiritual planes
22 explains that this is where living
humans go and they're so deeply into
their activities that they literally
transcend to a different plane of
existence
and 22 quickly points out that anyone
can enter under the right circumstances
including actors tattoo artists and
basketball players
of course 22 enjoys disturbing people in
the zone and takes particular pleasure
in thwarting a basketball player right
before he makes a basket telling joe
that she's been messing with that
particular team for decades a look at
their logo makes it clear that the team
in question is specifically the new york
knicks
making the line a reference to the nba
team's infamous losing streak
more than anything else that's a gag
meant for the knicks long-suffering
die-hard fans
after breaking out of the hospital in
joe's body 22 is understandably a little
overwhelmed by bustling streets of new
york city
and basically winds up huddling in a
corner joe now in the body of a cat
lures her out with a slice of pepperoni
pizza igniting 22's previously
undiscovered love
of food for the rest of the film 22 is
joe is rarely seen without some sort of
snack in her hand whether it's a piece
of pizza a bagel or even a half-consumed
slushie she finds underneath a seat on
the subway
one thing you might not notice however
is 22 is joe payne for any of that food
and that's because she probably didn't
while it's certainly possible that she's
using joe's phone to pay for some of it
it seems more probable given 22's
complete indifference to earthly customs
that she's just swiping whatever looks
good to her
after all she seems to have no concept
of money and is governed almost entirely
by the id segment of her personality
it would almost be more out of character
if she was stopping to pay
obviously this isn't something that's
going to cross younger minds but adults
will know all too well that there's no
such thing as a free lunch
no matter how good it smells in seoul
joe's journey to the afterlife and back
simply ends up being a matter of getting
his soul reunited with his body
as if it was only knocked loose by his
tumble into the manhole
and sure enough once joe finds his
comatose body in the hospital
all it takes is 22 diving inside for him
to be back on his feet
good as new although it still takes a
good amount of effort for joe to finally
get the jerrys and terry's to agree to
let his soul stay in his body the body
itself seems pretty much no worse for
the wear
while kids may accept this premise at
face value everyone else will probably
be left wondering just how joe is up and
walking around by the end as if nothing
happened
after all his injury was severe enough
to not only place him in a coma but also
jettison his soul to the afterlife
joe's presence in the great beyond seems
to imply that he was functionally dead
for a while
indicating that he suffered some sort of
traumatic brain injury at the very least
obviously it's great that joe gets a
second chance at the end of the film but
many viewers won't help but feel a
little nervous about joe's overall
health and wonder if the major trauma
sustained in his fall could have
significant repercussions for his
long-term well-being
or you know maybe everything will be
fine it is a movie after all
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one